voilà donc les shadoks jacques rouxel
vous en êtes le l'instigateur alors je
disais que vous avez déclenché les
événements de 68 parce que je crois que
le premier jour de diffusion c'était le
29 avril 68
we are revoir à revoir cet épisode je ne
vois pas en croit en dieu je déclare oui
ça vous fait il me semble de toute façon
on a commencé le 28 c'est le 28
c'est le 28 avril donc ça s'est passé le
premier diffusion alors qu'il était venu
cette idée que vous avez soumis je crois
au service de recherche de la rtf qui a
déclaré plus tôt pour promouvoir la
musique concrète
ah oui bien fait on fait de la recherche
avait été créée par pierre schaeffer
pour pour promouvoir la musique concrète
et puis ma foi on lui a dit à un moment
bon quand même ne fait pas que de la
musique c'est intéressant aussi de faire
de la télévision et du cinéma
et donc il a fait du cinéma et un beau
jour où on a fait les chéneaux on l'a
fait on en a fait comme ça très épisodes
qui sont restés dans le tiroir prendre
un certain temps et puis un beau jour il
est dit un monsieur de la télévision a
libéré de mantoue fille de 5 ans de ça
passe le 28 ça démarre tout de suite
c'est met encore une fois en regardant
le regardant ces choses ça n'avait rien
de pour déclencher une révolution vous
vous attendiez à ces réactions de de
diffusion nationale
absolument pas mais à cette époque là
vous savez tout le monde regardait la
télévision pratiquement à la même chaîne
à la même heure et ce serait bien
regarder des choses comme ça des petits
trucs filiforme sur l'écran ma foi ça a
pu scandalisé c'était évidemment inspiré
de tout un univers du non sens anglais
de peut-être que c'est ça aussi qui a
choqué de dire on était habitué à cette
forme d'humour là le principe de base
c'était de raconter des choses qui ne
veulent rien dire on cherche l'autre et
par là qu'ils soient du non sens
effectivement les shadoks avec la
pétanque le pied en bas qui servent à
soutenir des planètes pas en dessous ma
foi se sait jamais vu un bon alors c'est
certainement ça qui a fait qui a fait
qui a fait qui a scandalisé parce que
effectivement c'était pas ce n'est pas
tout à fait c'était pas tout à fait très
très chinois
alors le samedi 26 juin et le samedi 3
juillet de 22h à l'aube au passage du
nord-ouest à paris il ya l'intégrale des
shadoks qui est donné toute la nuit on
pourra voir l'intégrale haut que je
souhaite bon courage je trouve ces
personnes parce qu'il y en a sept heures
mais ça vaut le soulier de satin de
claudel avignon claude piéplu évidemment
la question qu'on se pose et les shadoks
sont désormais absolument inséparables
indissociable de votre voix est ce que
ça vous a gêné d'être à ce point
identifié à la voie des shadoks dans
l'est dans les mois qui ont directement
suivi oui ça aurait pu gêner le jeu il
fallait et surtout que j'évite de tomber
dans les pièges qui m'était tendu c'est
vrai que l'os on étiquette très vite les
comédiens et
après ce phénomène shadox j'aurais pu
être qu'une qu'une voie et être privé de
tout autre organe physique il fallait je
précise encore pendant un moment il a
fallu que je disais ok j'ai encore des
yeux un regard puis à partir de ce
regard peut-être une âme qui va passer
et si elle est belle ça peut encore ça
peut encore faire plaisir pas mal de
gens mais il a fallu que je le précise
on avait complètement oublié qui ça
pouvait encore exister que je peux plus
que je n'étais plus qu'une voie est
maintenant bien il y en a encore des
échos abbas est la référence est la
référence oui c'est la référence qui
vient au premier oui ça fait flipper
pompey est oui alors que je suis donné
mais quand même encore assez mal pour
pas mal d'autres choses
je suis quand même jouer la comédie à
djibouti c'était pas la guerre mais
enfin c'est quand même du soleil
j'ai joué comme si à ouagadougou à bobo
dioulasso à fianarantsoa enfin je pense
est un vrai pour la la grande
décentralisation sa personne ne m'en
parle
après quand même est un certain mérite
jouer l'école des femmes à djibouti avec
une perruque molière croyez moi que
c'est ça ment pas ne s'amendent pas de
mérite aussi
cela dit je suis ravi d'avoir fait des
shadoks jacques rouxel et je le souhaite
qu'une chose c'est d'en faire